hi everyone my name is Mike this is
actually the first time I've spoken at a
security conference and I have to admit
I'm starting to get paranoid just two or
three nights ago I was sitting at home
minding my own business and I got an
email through from Google someone is you
or your account has been recovered
successfully so oh what's going on so I
start digging in okay
two-factor enabled yes okay and it's
like okay so what just happened right I
don't know but it can't be a coincidence
the same week I'm gonna speak at a
security conference that my account
start getting hacked hmm so now it's now
I'm starting to worry about everything
in this after this morning I'm worried
about quantum cryptography and the
future of freedom and uh so okay so my
background is I've spent the last five
or six years as a DevOps consultant
actually helping organizations implement
DevOps which is in a way helping them
with software development life cycles is
just a I new way of saying the old thing
and usually it goes fine except where it
doesn't and the places where it doesn't
usually go well are places that security
is an issue
the challenges are faced by banks by
people making well you know all the the
story but these are very unique
situations so I've been spending a lot
of time on this in recent couple of
years and working with companies and
starting to see some patterns evolve so
I thought I would try and gather
together what what I've seen and what
works and to you know something that
will hopefully help
someone's hacked my pointer see I told
you this paranoia think was deep there
we go so well I do have a fancier gender
but who wants to read something I wrote
[Laughter]
really it's it's this talk is about
obviously around DevOps about how to
automate your software development
process in a way that makes sense for
compliance for people working in
regulated industries for people that are
working towards standards and then
security where those three things meet
but don't worry I do have a plan so it's
not all just made up on the spot so
we're gonna begin with a little bit of
Bingle guys are some seats in the front
here don't be shy does anyone know what
this is just shout out if you know it's
waterfall at it's a great way to make
software it's been in use for you know
50 60 years it works I think for the
most part I mean I jerk but it has been
relatively successful I mean it was the
way we made software for a long time and
it seemed to get us somewhere and our in
our state of evolution so it wasn't that
bad this was the paper that introduced
waterfall to the world by Winston Royce
he was writing about how we should make
software in the military and actually in
the paper he says this implementation
described above is risky and invites
failure but of course we only remember
the diagram so we implement the diagram
and this actually ended up becoming the
Department of Defense standard for
making software but that's a that's
another that's another story
what's this anyone seen this oh you're
all very lucky this is Prince - Prince -
is a project management framework I
suppose that was kind of operationalized
out of the British governments it seems
like the governments have always got
some hand in a lot of this bad stuff of
course there's a lot of criticism
against Prince because when it doesn't
went
projects failed that use prints they say
it's because well you have a news prints
correctly but when it works it's
obviously because the process is perfect
okay what's this one
hi year-old maybe too young I don't know
RUP missus rational unified process this
was an old or older way it was very
popular in the 90s to early mid 2000s
before agile became really popular this
was a very common way to do larger
software projects and organizations Ivar
Jacobson was one of the pioneers about
rough and rational unified process and
actually UML and all kinds of stuff he's
a quite an interesting guy but he and an
interview saying well actually branded
processes like rapport extreme
programming or because they're all just
a collection of practices instead
practices will become first-class
citizens so ok maybe the frameworks are
not that interesting this one I'm sure
you've seen before what's this scrum
yeah and of course scrum is perfect too
this is Ron Jeffries he says I'm coming
to think developers of all stripes
should have no adherence to any agile
method of any kind and this is the guy
that came up with that agile so there we
go
but again I mean all of these
methodologies have been able to deliver
some value right one last one this is
the V model it's very popular if you're
making medical devices or if you're
making automotive software this kind of
stuff where you've got yeah if you're
trying to adhere to some kind of ISO
standard usually around software nearly
all of them have some kind of V model in
them and of course they have their fair
share of criticism as well which we
won't go into one more
I picked through the Japanese version of
the diagram just to make it a little bit
harder this is my personal favorite it's
the one that I get up against all the
time as I told anyone ever worked in an
organization that follows I - did you
enjoy it it's a it's again this is
coming from it's coming from British
government so it's not just lately the
British government's been a bit wacky
it's it's been for a long for a long
long time plenty of criticism about it--
so especially nowadays where a lot of
ISIL is about you know putting in gates
and processes and controls into the
development process which feels kind of
antiquated these days this one ah DevOps
and of course there's nothing wrong with
DevOps it's perfect it's the magical
unicorn that will solve all your
problems and that's why you're at this
talk no of course that's not true either
like every process I mean really
following a diagram or not it's not
going to be the thing that decides
whether you are successful it's not
going to decide whether your customers
want your product was not going to
decide whether you're secure
they're just frameworks for thinking and
in the end it's always gonna be people
that are really what make the difference
in in the software development so what
can we learn from all of these different
methodologies that we've had throughout
history well one thing is that they all
have a diagram this is very important if
you want to come up with your own
methodology you must create a diagram
first it's the only way it will stick
and we know this because with scrum
scrum was the first agile method to have
a diagram at Crystal XP all of those
things they didn't really have a diagram
that looked like the process I think
that that is why scrum succeeded and I
also think that's why safe is succeeding
right now because they've got this fancy
diagram they will all eventually be
ridiculed so whatever whatever process
you've pop in to pick today you just
have to accept that in five years you're
going to be
but it's part of the process it's just
natural shouldn't worry about that the
most important thing is that they're all
subject to confirmation bias so nearly
always if you like a process you'll see
all successes with that process as being
due to the process and f.f
project fails with your favorite process
you will assume it's because somebody
didn't do it right it's kind of like
security right
a lot of confirmation bias and speaking
of safe you know these these frameworks
encourage a lot of template thinking
they're often really really attractive
to organizations that would really
rather avoid making decisions right
because you would you'd rather just
someone else did the thinking and we can
just apply the template if we read the
book and follow the process take the
training get certified then we'll know
what to do and then you know we're
finally a we're finally going to fix
what's wrong with us and the reason is
completely natural we go through this
over and over in Thomas Kuhn wrote this
book in 68 which was about the way
science changes over time so anyone read
it
it's an awful book don't read it it's
really truly terrible
it's very dense academic you know one
sentence goes for a whole page kind of
stuff but it's very very difficult to
read but it had some very very
influential and good ideas in it and
that's why it's worth talking about what
he realized was he was a doing a PhD in
physics at University in America and as
part of his job at the University he had
to teach an undergraduate course and
over four liberal liberal arts majors
around the history of science and in
doing so he started to see a pattern
over and over again and how science
actually progresses which was different
from how people assumed it does or
talked about it even scientists where
it's you know it's quite common for
scientists just to say we make
hypothesis we test it we take the
conclusions and keep going around and
missus and of incremental improvement
our ideas this is what science says
maybe it is
if you zoom out far enough but actually
if you look closely at science the way
it works is in a cycle and and generally
you have one you have a paradigm and
actually in this book is where the
certain paradigm shift comes from so you
have a paradigm and the paradigm is
basically the the shared worldview that
you and all your colleagues in your
field have whatever that happens to be
well it could be like some examples from
from the Booker he talks about going
through from geocentric thinking to
heliocentric thinking to Newtonian
physics to Einstein in physics to
quantum theory so they're all kind of
paradigms of how things work in the
cosmos for instance and what happens is
that you live in a paradigm everybody in
your field shares that paradigm you have
a shared basis you have usually shared
education and this thing but if over
time I normally start to creep in some
things don't add up more and more and
albany's grow until scientists start to
question the very foundation of the
field and then you get to a crisis where
you know all the ideas are getting flung
around and like people are looking for
this new kind of underpinning that's
going to going to get you through this
crisis and what takes you through that
is this idea that you have you need a
new theory which replaces the old theory
like the old theory that where where the
center of the universe and everything is
swishing by us - okay maybe we're going
around the Sun and the Sun is going
around other things and with you need
that new theory and you need data to
back that new theory and that will bring
you around through the revolution into a
paradigm change we're gonna throw out
the old paradigm and you bring in the
new one and people that hang on to the
old paradigm usually kind of get written
out of their fields they're not very
interesting anymore if you didn't get
with Newtonian physics you know in the
17th century then you were probably not
a leading thought a thought leader in
your in your field for instance and we
can see this cycle in software too you
know going through all
those different cycles especially the
one from I would say waterfall thinking
to to agile thinking I'll stack or burn
he was also one of the co-authors of the
agile manifesto yeah this article was
published in the communications of the
ACM back in 99 so before the agile
manifesto came out it's not online
anymore because he's websites down but
you can find on the wayback machine and
he talks about people as non linear
first-order components and software
development which is a weird way of
putting it but what he's saying is that
he was a he was really into methodology
into software development life cycles
and he would go to organizations and
bring a methodology to try out on them
what I realized is that when he did that
most people in the team didn't care they
didn't care about his new fancy
methodology and the second thing he
realized is they were able to ignore him
and get on with the work anyway and then
he that led him to think okay well if
I'm being humble about this what what we
learned
well the learning is that you know
projects succeed and fill and you can
succeed in any methodology any
methodology can be made to work with the
right people and the best methodology in
the world was the wrong people will
never work so what he saw is that the
people are the most important aspect of
your methodology in the end and I think
that that's really important we often
get stuck into free especially in you
know when we start talking about DevOps
and so on we start getting to think
about frameworks and what is this and
what is that and tools and so on but
it's actually the people and how they
behave and how they interact and how
they do their work is going to be the
biggest difference than any other
methodology you can think of right given
that we will end up ridiculing whatever
we pick and that most of them are
rubbish why would we want to do it
place well Richard Branson seems to
think we shouldn't he says you don't
learn to walk by following the rules you
learn by doing and following over that's
probably not bad advice if you're a
businessman if you want to try and
create a new product or start a new
service you know going out and you know
failing is actually the way to do it but
it's not very good advice if you make
software that can control economies
manages money that can drive cars that
can control your insulin pump or that
manages the the bridge that you cross
every day and there's a lot of software
that you actually probably do want to
learn by failing and that's kind of what
this talk is about you know when when
you want to solve for that problem and
sometimes you just don't have any choice
sometimes you need to define a
methodology maybe you work in a
regulated industry maybe you make
financial software maybe you work in a
bank and the you will have governing
bodies or governments making rules for
you and these rules and regulations are
things that you're obliged to follow for
instance to keep your banking license so
what you do you inside your company you
look at those regulations and you
translate them into your internal
processes and this kind of process of
translation is usually very messy
because the regulations have built up
over the years and so of your processes
and have been done at different times by
different people so many of the
processes you have in your organization
you don't know why anymore you don't
know whether they're to meet some
regulatory need or if they just happen
to have been some manager 17 years ago
really liked ITIL and thought that a
change advisory board was necessary so
you have all this process that involves
usually a lot of meetings and sign offs
and a lot of documentation because at
some point the auditors are going to
come in and have a look and they're
going to say well show me how to you
meet your regulations you show them your
process document I'm so great now prove
to me that you do what you say in your
process document and that takes a lot of
time energy usually a lot of effort to
get to an audit is anyone working in a
regulated industry right now okay yeah
so other than regulate regulated
industries there's a lot of
organizations that want to or need to
follow ISO standards like if you're
making automotive software then you're
kind of obliged to follow ISO 26262 many
organizations just follow ISO standards
because the customers demand it it gives
them access to a market that they
couldn't have unless they had followed
the standard some ISO standards are
required for instance to work offshore
and oil and gas but the overall
reasoning behind following an ISO
standard is also to reduce costs because
the idea is that if you define a
standard you will reduce the number of
errors in your process at least process
related errors and this is Atul Gawande
had very nice big what she don't
actually have to read either for the for
the record because all you need to know
is the checklists actually work to
reduce errors and if you understand that
then you can figure out where and you're
in your world it makes sense to have
justice where are you forgetting steps
in your process but they do instill a
higher kind of discipline and this is
the kind of discipline we'd like to
bring to our software process if we're
following and before in a regulated
entry and we want to follow some kind of
standard so we're in specially
specifically in the this world of
compliance that the scope is across the
whole the whole value stream in a sense
from the customer needs to being
delivered so you can start from product
management is it even legal to make this
feature this is a question you have to
ask are we allowed to make this feature
is that does it comply with whatever
data standards that we have to
do we have to legally tell our customers
about this change do we have to if we're
in a bank we have to tell the branch
managers that about this change what has
to happen in this product management
sphere will have to be part of your
compliance process and then over maybe
on the delivery side of the chain when
it comes to IT operations you're
thinking about what what are what is our
network security policies how are we
managing data recovery in disaster
recovery how are we doing backups all of
this stuff has to be taken care of and
then in meadow you've got software
development which is usually where the
Wild West of the processes because you
know this is where all of the the
changes in general being created in the
system and it's so much changed that
it's really hard for any end of the
value stream to really have visibility
into so what organizations tend to do is
to try and bring in a lot of process
around this to manage that risk we need
to have for every release we need to
have this documentation we need to have
this information we need to sign offs
from QA we need and and this is a
natural response to to that volume of
change coming because we're basically
asking how much risk are we accepting
here unless we know what's going on so
the the typical response is to bring a
lot of paperwork to that problem
now Tim Ottinger says that one piece
going around organizations 90% of the
software process is really a software
prevention process and I think that's
right because mostly the software
process doesn't talk about how to make
software it's about how you control the
quality of software so it's all about
putting gates and checks and and
standards into the process very little
in the process is about how to produce
great stuff and get it into the hands of
the customers
and he says well if you really want to
prevent delivery to the customer we're
gonna add silos batches queues approvals
and gates so how do we get rid of all of
that stuff while staying compliant while
staying secure whilst whilst having a
control over environment and this is
where I think that DevOps are starting
to bring some answer to to to those
questions because a lot of the paperwork
doesn't need to exist anymore there's
this famous parable about I think it's
Chinese maybe it's African I'm not sure
I think every parable is Chinese in the
end but it's if you have different
people looking at an elephant and like
you see I'm looking at a spear I'm
looking at a wall I'm looking at a phone
I'm looking at a rope because they don't
see the big picture but the joke is were
DevOps is exactly the opposite no matter
what you look at you see DevOps so it
could be about culture and organization
and bringing different silos together it
could be about deployment automation it
could be about all kinds of different
practices but everyone just kind of
flops the word DevOps on it and kind of
yeah it's DevOps so it's good at least
no but in remember in five years time
DevOps it's going to be embarrassing and
we'll think we should never have done it
but maybe maybe there's something in
this whole magical unicorn that can help
us through the compliance maze so the
thing about DevOps is it is a socio
technical system and it's messy because
it's about people it's I mean the whole
word DevOps comes from bringing
development and operations together to
solve problems which makes sense and now
of course it means more than that
because it means bringing security and
and compliance and QA and the whole idea
is that you want everybody that's part
of the value stream working together to
deliver on that value stream so we're
trying to merge the the the silos
organizationally trying to bring the
skills together to solve problems but
it's also technical there's no getting
around it that what if we're DevOps came
from is a word to describe how
development and operations work together
so
ensure that they can deliver high
quality at fast rates securely so this
is a diagram from AWS which I really
like because it's very different from
what you normally see when like if you
look back at all of those those diagrams
were processed the nearly all involves
cycles but this one from AWS is a bit
different which I think it's a bit more
honest because what you have is a
pipeline that ends up going to the
customer and they're going to swallow
whatever you get and then hopefully
you're getting some feedback from that
world so it's definitely it feels more
like a bi-directional thing than a cycle
to me so I like this there's a lot of
research going into DevOps as well which
is quite nice it's the first time we've
actually put some numbers on how process
effects change and in the world so to
get the folks at Dora led by Nicole for
screen I've been doing research for the
last seven or eight years asking
thousands of IT professionals across the
world questions about how they make
software how they deliver software how
they respond to failures and so on and
now we've got some really good numbers
about the differences between the best
performing and the lowest performing of
course there's a big difference in
organizations we know this already but
what they see is that that having a lot
of practices around DevOps helps having
the ability to respond to failure really
quickly helps if you have a deployment
that fails how quickly can you recover
from that that's actually a useful
number to know and with their research
they tell you that's the financial
performance of the organization so what
they find is that organizations that are
good at DevOps are also usually much
better than average or in their
financial performance not sure which
direction the weather DevOps makes money
or money makes DevOps but at least
there's there's a connection there
but I think that compliance and security
is also a technology technique social
technical technical system whereas
compliance has typically been like if
you work in a bank compliance is a
different Department it's it's it's it's
actually designed to be like an external
person coming in to audit so you might
have it's very commonly and at least in
Norway you talk about the three lines of
defense so you have on the the third
line of defense is financed docena
external auditors coming and making sure
the bank is doing what it's supposed to
and then the second line of Defense's
internal audit and they're going in
looking and making sure the teams are
doing what they're supposed to and then
the first line of defense is like the
people actually doing the work and
they're making sure that they're doing
the right thing but what I think is that
we need to bring bridge some of this gap
between DevOps and compliance to make it
easier for DevOps to deliver because if
you don't do something around how you
manage security and compliance and
you're in you're on the left side of the
diagram you don't you're not able to go
any faster than your compliance
processes can manage an example is the
change advisory board has anyone been in
a change advisory board meeting okay
this is where all the action happens so
for those of you that haven't changed
advisory board is something I think
actually also coming out of the ITIL
standard where it began but the idea is
that if you want to put a change into
production this is part of the service
transition part of ìtell and then what
we're going to do is we're going to all
get in a room and discuss the change and
make sure that the change is okay to go
into production we've done the correct
testing with them the correct risk
management makes sense right it makes
sense if you're releasing once every
three months or once every six months or
once every year to go and and you know
have we done all the testing have we
done all this if you want to release so
the new version of your bank every five
minutes or every even just daily you
can't convene a meeting that's going to
look into all of this every single day
it's just not possible the thing is the
change Advisory Board is living on right
now in an org in organizations in banks
and banks that you bank with right now
they have change advisory board meetings
and it's really risk theater because the
volume of change that's going through
those kab meetings is so high that
they've got no idea whether the risk is
being managed or not it doesn't stop
failures from happening in production
that's it's it's just a bit of cargo
cult that we have from our previous
processes which is a real shame and it's
also been research into this so the
doric folks have been asking about
change advisory boards and what they say
is that from the data that they get back
in their surveys external approvals we
had a change advisory board or IT change
management team or whatever it is
they're negatively correlated with lead
time makes sense if you're going to have
to have a meeting before you can do
something then it's going to delay how
long you how long it takes to get it out
and deployment frequency also restore
time it changes your time to recover
from failures because you often have to
create emergency channels for fixes and
find other ways to do this change
management process by the data it says
it is in fact worse than having no
change approval process at all that will
make you slower and make it harder to
recover from failure and it doesn't
include improve the quality that's
that's a good data point there's the the
folks at IT revolution which also are
they're connected to the doora team they
had a summit around DevOps and odd and
how these things can go together and I
mean they're highlighting the risk the
cab exists for a good reason the absence
of change approval or controls creates
the risk of untested and unauthorized I
would say or unauthorized code being
introduced into production and this is
exactly what you don't want I you
definitely want to solve for this
problem the point is that the cab
doesn't solve for this problem either
because it's really hard to know whether
untested code or unauthorized code is in
a release if you've got hundreds of
commits and a release it's really just
not possible for somebody external to
make that decision so what do we do the
this manual process becomes the blocker
of course it does another interesting
thing if we go back to this translation
process from regulations to how we
implement the security in our
organizations is that our interpretation
of the regulations is often not what's
actually written in the regulations I
was doing I was doing an engagement for
a bank in Australia and everybody said
to me we had to do the cap because of
our guidelines operas the financial Cena
for America for Australia so we have to
do the cab for the Opera we have to have
somebody from IT doing the deploy
because we need segregation of duties we
have to do that it's written in the
standard so okay well where's the
standard right yeah I don't know so I go
and look it up online I print it out and
then over a couple of nights I read it
it doesn't say any of that stuff
it really doesn't it's just how they've
interpreted it internally and there's
lots of organizations taking different
approaches that are also managing to
somehow keep their banking license so we
have to start to wonder you know how do
we control how do we know how much of
this is from what we've interpreted and
how much of this is actually necessary
another another challenge in this world
is that if you have gone through a
successful audit you're you're likely to
want to keep your process exactly the
same as it's always been because you
know that doing it this way will get you
through an audit
and that's the that's the heart
challenge then you have to try and brick
but what they found is that DevOps can
be a better audit compliance this is
actually how the rent and the document
but you get the point it's it is a title
but this is this is how it's written the
DevOps is better practices so and it's
not just written down in documents by
people who are researchers it's also
what companies are doing right now if
you look good this is this is ing
talking about how they do compliance as
code and how they have compliance
dashboards and how they enforce
compliance and their pipelines Capital
One is doing the same thing there's many
many of the the banks that are actually
starting now or more of the the new
banks are doing it in this way and
what's interesting is that the reason
they're doing it isn't because they're
greenfield or because they're new but
doing it because they don't have 20 or
30 years of legacy processes built up
legacy organization built up around how
they make the software right let's get
to security so say we we say okay let's
try and how do we go faster while making
sure that we don't have the risk of
untested or unsecure code going into
production well one thing is that we
could as an industry start spending more
money on it like if you look at software
security this is a research done by he
wasn't now it was IDC and Gartner so
little goes into the software
development part of the lifecycle lots
into Network and host security lots into
date and people's security but very
little into the software part system
which i think is a it's a shame because
there's a real risk there at google they
think that insider threat is one of the
biggest things that their processes have
to deal with i'll talk about what they
do later but as one of their key
security principles is to say we not
only need to be secure against ourselves
but against the outside world but we
have to be secure and and the fact that
we we don't know if somebody internal is
trying to deploy
tested or unverified code to production
how do we make sure our process are
built for that and by them and that also
includes the idea that if like your
credentials are stolen and someone
steals your credentials pretends to be
you and Google and tries to deploy
something nefarious so we want to have
insider threat as a goal managing that
we want to probably conform to some kind
of process if we want to follow well if
we're in a regulated industry if we want
to follow an ISO standard would we just
want to be good we probably want to
define our process write it down so then
it can be more or less a checklist to go
through probably want to have two pairs
of eyes on every piece of code code
reviews this is also something we can
check automatically as part of the
development pipeline adherence to coding
standards this is very common and
automotive embedded these kind of safety
critical systems but not so much in
banks and so on but at least this is
something you can check you want to
check verifiable builds you want to make
sure that the build that you've created
you know will every you have a manifest
for everything that's inside it and you
can cryptographically be secure that
this binary is the one you built in the
in your pipeline and this this is the
one that you've deployed might want to
check and tests have executed correctly
and you've got coverage you hope for
some static analysis vulnerability
scanning this is becoming more and more
common and verifiable deployments and
this goes back to the verifiable builds
if you know what you built then we need
to apply it you can check whether you
built it or somebody else built it
and then of course you also need some
traceability you know you need to
replace all of this meetings in
sign-offs with automated processes and
you need to change this continuous
documentation to be something that's
produced automatically by your pipelines
so if you say if you say we must have
code reviews on every change that goes
through our pipeline you should record
that you've done the code review
somewhere in your pipeline and you
probably want to have a mutable
infrastructure and this is really a lot
easier to do these days with tools like
docker because you can run your
application and a container it's nothing
magical about that but you can also in
that container say that the file system
is read-only and that's huge because
once you have a read-only file system a
lot of it attacks kind of disappear a
lot of attacks are involving getting a
script on to your desk and then
executing it to curl down something else
which is going to mine Bitcoin or
whatever is the cool thing to do these
days so if you can make your even your
runtime environment immutable have have
a read-only file system have some
controls on that and also have an
identification for everything in your
system like your software package like
your daughter am I just like your VM
images if you can give them a
cryptographic hash so between those two
things you get full traceability to make
sure that what's running in production
is what you expect to be running in
production and to pal from Capital One
Bank says that if everything is source
code like if you're building all your
environments and you're building your
packages at three of you through
automated means then you also need no
access to production so if you're not
writing anything to desk if you're not
if there's a there's nothing happening
on on that and production machine then
you nobody needs access and another
thing you want to do is to try and
standardize tooling you don't want every
team to decide their own tools because
you have a massive attack service if if
one team picks take an example if one
yeah even if one team
Peck's AWS and one team picks azure high
securing both of those environments is
huge so that's just one way but it comes
down to the individual tools you're
using as well the frameworks I mean if
you can try and limit the the frameworks
and then you'd have far less projects to
check four CVEs and so on it's also
faster to onboard new users and projects
and if everybody is using the same
version of Ruby for instance or the same
version of a bin - it's really easy to
upgrade it across the whole fleet but if
every different team is running a
different flavor of a operating system
or running a different flavor of the the
programming language is really hard to
solve for security problems so o ASP
they talked they used to have a secure
software development lifecycle project I
believe it was called but recently they
changed it to the Software Assurance
maturity model so it's more I mean it is
Security's baked into it of course
because coming from from OS but they do
have a working group that's looking
around these kind of aspects on on the
software development chain and when it
comes to build and deployment of I mean
what they're saying is basically use
DevOps at the top maturity level build
process helps prevent knowing defects
from answering the production
environment that's means you're driving
that assurance inside your pipelines and
then the deployment process is fully
automated and incorporates the automated
verification of these critical
milestones they're using the word
milestones but in banks it's more
typical to talk about controls so on the
subject of implementing compliance
controls how would you even get started
and I think that the first place to
start is to figure out where you are now
and this is actually a harder process
than you would expect because in order
to do the value stream mapping for
say the user need all the way through to
production change and a large enough
organization you will cross many many
different teams you'll need to have
someone who knows IT change management
someone who knows the network security
someone who knows the QA process someone
who knows the compliance officers
obviously the developers and the testers
and you end up with you know 20 30
people to be able to actually do a
proper value stream map once you know
like what your whole process is then
it's - coming to decide like what
controls do you have now and what
controls do you wanna have in the future
and figuring out where to where to where
to automate your process and where to
put the controls in so that's the next
step like what you want to do is to say
okay from from the need to it going into
production there is some kind of network
of things that has to happen you
probably want to figure out where the
controls are and and and automate that
whole as much of that process as you can
do now when it comes to compliance you
also need to record that you've done
these controls so right now you're
typically running around all these
different systems to figure out if
you're if you've got this compliance
data that you need but what you should
just do is to put it in a system of
record like get-get is a perfect place
to store compliance data because it's
immutable it's an append-only journal if
you change data you just get a new
version of it there's a lot of good
reasons to use get as your system of
record so as you go through your
pipeline do your controls but also
record it and some in system of record
like git because then you have perfect
audit trail and then the next step is to
actually enforce compliance in the
pipelines make sure all your security
controls have been done before something
can be merged into your say your master
branch or before someone can be promoted
in your artifact management system
and you probably want to have automated
release controls as well because at some
stage you're going to send a collection
of changes to production and you need
insight over that as well to manage the
risk and that's really yet
that's the kind of step-by-step process
what about the security culture just
some learnings from different from
different companies in different areas
one of the things that you should really
aim for is just having one pipeline it's
kind of like standardized tooling if you
have a small subset of tooling if you
have only one pipeline then it's a lot
easier to add security controls to add
compliance controls in the pipeline but
if every team is creating their own
pipelines adding security controls
becomes a big problem so what ing D they
started with nothing and they ended up
with 740 applications going through the
same pipeline very very different
applications you need to find a way to
make it happen but you can do it this is
a capital one this is the the controls
that they put into their pipeline yeah
version control static analysis code
coverage vulnerability stand open source
scan artifact version control all this
stuff anything that goes into production
must go through all of these controls
and when we talked earlier about Google
they have this thing called binary
authentication for borg borg is there
it's basically their kubernetes this is
where they shed your workloads in
production and in Google and what they
do is that before anything well Bob is
kind of like it's a system that every
deployment makes that must go through
before it makes it to production and it
works in three ways you can have audit
you can have deploy time checks and you
can have continuous checks so in an
audit mode you give Bob a policy like
the list of security controls you expect
your software to have done
then as you go to deploy you will ask
Bob will ensure that you've got all of
that evidence before you can go into
production and Google servers and this
was going back to their insider threat
problem this is how they make sure that
everything that goes to production has
has been authorized and has been called
reviewed so first off you start by in
audit mode just getting the feedback
getting the alerts if you're not and
then the next thing is to actually have
it as a control point where you get you
don't get to production unless you have
everything and then the third level is
to automatically go around checking
production monitoring the different
versions of the different systems that
are running and making sure that they
have all the compliance checks in real
time what they say is automating these
checks have been any enabled the
compliance team to increase both the
scope of services covered by in their
compliance framework and their security
frameworks but also increase the
adoption of appropriate controls so more
of their their systems are under control
and they can add more controls to the
system very easily so this has been
really important for them so that's what
I wanted to share hope it was useful I
just want to say that like DevOps is a
buzzword we're going to end up thinking
it's ridiculous it's going to be like a
magical unicorn and five years time it's
going to be embarrassing that I even
came to a conference to talk about it
sorry in future me but it does actually
help when it comes to security and
compliance because it may allow you to
add a lot of security controls build a
lot of security controls and your
pipelines automatically so I hope you
got something from this Thanks
[Applause]
yeah if you have any questions just come
up and talk to me